,
et quand on se compare, qu'est-
ce que ça donne? Marie-Josée
Paquette-VComeau.
- Qu'ils essaient d'arrêter
dangereux.
- Le SPVM embauchera
450 nouveaux policiers.
Mais, plus d'effectifs,
est-ce la solution. émérite,. é,
Départ. de criminologie, uOttawa
- Pas du tout. Le nombre
d'effectif n'est pas du tout
relié au niveau de fusillade.
PIERSON 'est
plus gagnant pour nos élus
d'avoir ce discours.
- La Ville de Vancouverr
100 000 habitants.
À Winnipeg, 176;
Toronto, 167.
Et c'est à Montréal que l'on
déjà plus de policiers,
soit 204 par 100 000 habitants
de gravité de criminalitémoins i
de la métropole.
d'augmenter le total
des effectifs, c'est d'employer
le nombre d'effect
de manière différente.
ANDRÉ DUROCHER,
inspecteur à la - Je pense qu'ie
un exercice de fone
vraiment structuré :
quelles sont les t
quelles sont les fonctions
qui sonttuellement,
par exemple, par des policiers
qui pourraient être faitesnnes??
- L'ancien membre du SPVMregrets
pour le déploiement des
effectifs ou sa réa population.
- Voici ce qu'on a besoin, puis
voici où on va les mettre,
parce que, actuellement...
Mais mêais : "Bon, on va mettre
dans CENTAURE, dans ci,
dans ça..." Un moment donné,
on va créer tellement
d'escouarefaire refaire refairer
coordonner les escouades.
- Depuis 20 ans, plusieurs
chercheurs se sont penchés sur
les meilleures prae urbaine.
- Ce que je vois à Montréal,c'ee
qui est au courant
ni le gouvernement du Québec.
- Investir dans les travailleurs
des services sociaux :
la science démontre que
le renforcement du filet social
- Puis, toutes les annonces
qui vontites, làites, làites, l,
50 % en prévention,
50 % en système de justice, la e
complètement.
- Pour l'instant, 225 millions
de dollars seront réservés
aux poli travailleurs sociaux.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Mon